[Musique]
vous avez été réunis aujourd'hui et nous
vous en remercions pour une discussion
qui prend place dans le cadre de la
grande consultation que the chief
project organise autour du plan de
transformation de l'économie française
avant de démarrer cette discussion il
nous a paru intéressant de vous rappeler
quelques éléments qui caractérisent le
dossier climatique
le premier c'est que de gré ou de force
nous n'échapperons pas à la réduction
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre ça
sera degrés si vous souhaitons limiter
la dérive climatique
ça sera deux forces si nous attendons
simplement l'épuisement des combustibles
fossiles qui suivra pas loin derrière un
certain nombre de pays ou de régions
dans le monde sont déjà en stress
d'approvisionnement énergétique ce qui
entrave déjà le fonctionnement de leur
économie et l'europe
malheureusement en fait partie en ce qui
concerne le réchauffement climatique
il faut garder en mémoire que c'est un
peu comme pour un nourrisson
si la température d'un nourrisson
augmente de 1 degré bon il est un peu
mal fichu des personnes ne s'affollent
tron si la température d'un nourrisson
augmentent de 5 degrés c branle bas de
combat et on craint pour sa vie
il en ira exactement de même avec le
climat chaque demi degré compte chaque
dixième de degré compte dès lors qu'on
commence à se rapprocher des seuils de
danger et nous y allons tout droit à
quelques degrés l'élévation de
température du climat planétaire
il faut rappeler que nous jouons avec
l'avis de quelques milliards d'individus
et l'espérance de vie pour quelques
dizaines d'années par personne nous
jouons également avec la stabilité de la
démocratie avec la paix et le simple
fait de pouvoir manger à sa faim pour un
nombre croissant de personnes
le plan dont le shift project s'est
emparé et d'un plan de réorientation
collective de nos activités
aujourd'hui ça n'est pas cela que nous
allons tester donc nous n'allons pas
vous demander de juger de la pertinence
des mesures que nous proposons dans
l'agriculture où l'administration
publique
par contre nous allons essayer de voir
si le volet efforts individuels qui va
nécessairement avec ce plan a été bien
dimensionné si nous avons en tête les
bonnes mesures pour demander à chacun
l'effort qui lui revient et c'est de
cela
nous souhaitons discuter ensemble mais
ne perdez pas de vue que à nouveau ce
plan est un plan collectif de
réorientation de l'activité du pays dont
vous pourrez par ailleurs découvrir
l'ensemble des mesures à partir de
septembre prochain
encore merci de vous prêter à cet
exercice bon débat